journée nationale d'action des chômeurs
des défilés dans plusieurs villes de
france l'unedic des blocs 15 millions de
francs d'être d'urgence invités nicole
notât président de l'unedic pollution
sur la région parisienne une enquête
montre l'aggravation des maladies et
même des décès causés par ce phénomène
atmosphérique contre l'échec scolaire un
professeur de race regroupe tous les
adolescents de la troisième à la
terminale pour les remettre à niveau et
leur faire aimer les études enquêtes
dans ce journal
johnny hallyday à coeur ouvert pour la
première fois le chanteur se confesse au
journal le monde la drogue et surtout
une jeunesse solidaire qui a conditionné
toute sa vie madame monsieur bonsoir la
journée nationale d'action des chômeurs
s'est traduite par une série de défis
les plus ou moins importants dans
plusieurs villes de province et à paris
une manifestation devant le siège de
l'unedic l'assurance chômage qui tenait
son conseil d'administration aujourd'hui
et sur lequel beaucoup compté pour
mettre un terme à l'action engagée par
les chômeurs pendant les fêtes de fin
d'année laurent bailly sébastien guibert
plusieurs milliers de manifestants cet
après midi devant le siège de l'unedic
venus à l'appel des associations de
chômeurs et de plusieurs syndicats
ils veulent vivre mieux
la moitié d'entre eux touchent moins de
4000 francs par mois chômage alors je
viens aussi à vous encore espérer que
j'arriverai à trouver une solution avant
d'arriver complètement en panne droit à
l'extérieur colère et pression sur
l'unedic à l'intérieur des
administrateurs syndicats et patronat
côte à côte qui renvoie à l'état la
charge d'assurer la solidarité nationale
est une présidente nicole notât qui a
déçu y compris dans son propre camp
on attend beaucoup de nicole notât on
attend le dialogue pas seulement le
dialogue avec les gens qui sont censés
représentatif d'après ces critères mais
le dialogue avec toutes les composantes
des gens qui s'ouvre mais pour la cgt
qui appelle les chômeurs à poursuivre
leur action
le vrai problème ce n'est pas nicolas
nota connaughton hop est 10% dans le
conseil d'administration de l'unedic
c'est le patronat calculs voire à
l'unedic et qui après réussi à faire à
différents moments des alliances dans un
sens ou dans un autre
en arrivant devant le ministère des
finances la manifestation s'est
dispersée dans le calme mais les
chômeurs préviennent leurs colères doit
être entendu si ce n'est pas entendus il
ya danger derrière il faut donc que le
gouvernement fasse très très vite
bourgeois pousser les partenaires
sociaux à prendre une décision ou bien
lui même prendre ses responsabilités en
la matière jusqu'où irez-vous régis cas
jusqu'à ce que le dernier en dépit des
tentatives d'apaisement de l'unedic
la mobilisation ne désarme donc pas ce
soir quelques manifestants ont investi
les voies de la gare de lyon pendant une
heure en vaquant l'intervention de la
police
plusieurs actions spectaculaires et
défilés ont donc marqué cette journée
dans plusieurs villes de province le
défis les plus importants ayant eu lieu
à marseille d'où est partie d'ailleurs
ce mouvement damien thévenot
c'est à marseille que la mobilisation a
été la plus forte et d'un millier de
manifestants ont défilé ce matin dans le
calme et sous un soleil estival chômeurs
et salariés main dans la main pour
réclamer du travail pour tous à travers
les générations manifestation sous le
signe de la solidarité
cinq cents personnes ont répondu
présentes à l'appel de la cgt et d'agir
ensemble contre le chômage
à carcassonne c'est la gare que les
chômeurs ont décidé d'investir une
centaine de manifestants ont bloqué les
trains pendant plus d'une heure tout est
rentré dans l'ordre en milieu d'après
midi
enfin passage en force au futuroscope de
poitiers les chômeurs sont entrées
gratuitement dans le parc de loisirs au
nom du droit à la culture eux aussi
comme dans une vingtaine d'autres villes
en france réclamaient une revalorisation
de leurs allocations manifestations dans
les rues débat à l'assemblée nationale
également martine aubry le ministre de
l'emploi de la solidarité est intervenue
comme beaucoup de socialistes elle a
évolué dans sa position depuis la
semaine dernière elle comprend le
mouvement désespéré des chômeurs jean
baptiste auprès d'ali al un poids assez
martine aubry le savait on guettait ses
réponses sur le mouvement des chômeurs à
l'assemblée nationale il lui a fallu
rompre le silence qu'elle observait
depuis deux jours à quatre reprises
l'opposition mais aussi la majorité
l'ont questionné alors le ministre de
l'emploi s'est d'abord efforcé de change
et taux
la réponse de l'emploi celles
qu'attendent tous les chômeurs cette
réponse prend du temps or certains
aujourd'hui n'ont pas le temps ils n'ont
pas le temps d'attendre
c'est pourquoi nous devons répondre à
l'urgence nous devons répondre à toutes
ces mains tendues
nous devons répondre par des réponses
concrètes dans les couloirs les plus
critiques à gauche comme les verts ou
les communistes prennent acte de cette
inflexion
notez dans ces propos un certain
changement de ton par rapport à sa
conférence de presse de samedi
une prise en compte plus plus nette de
ce que représente l'aspiration à la
dignité du mouvement des chômeurs mais
j'attends toujours que cela se traduise
par des mesures plus concrètes
à droite le rpr n'a pas encore pris
position
mais l'udf se montre critique résolument
gouvernement découvre maintenant qu'il
faut prendre des mesures d'urgence le
fait dans la précipitation
tout ça n'est pas sérieux ce
gouvernement a parlé beaucoup et a fait
très peu il continue d'ailleurs à parler
beaucoup et il fait très peu
martine aubry elle a continué à
s'expliquer devant la commission des
affaires sociales de l'assemblée par
exemple comme si le ministre de l'emploi
occupé le terrain avant que lionel
jospin s'exprime la mer réaction en date
le front national bruno mégret qui
représente qui présente son parti comme
le parti des chômeurs estime que ces
chômeurs qui sont entrés en révolte sont
manipulés par la cgt le parti communiste
il ne cautionne pas ce mouvement avant
de recevoir donc nicole notât et de
faire le point avec elle sur ce qu'a
décidé de lui ai dit que cet après midi
pour y voir plus clair d'abord faisons
un premier point entre les demandes des
chômeurs et que ce qu'ils ont obtenu à
l'heure qu'il est jean-paul challet les
associations de chômeurs réclame une
prime de fin d'année de 3000 francs elle
demande également un relèvement de 1500
francs par mois des minima sociaux comme
l'allocation pour les chômeurs en fin de
droits deux revendications qui n'ont
reçu aucun écho favorable
l'unedic qui gère l'assurance chômage à
calculer ce que coûterait la prime
annuelle si elle était versée à tous les
chômeurs 9 milliards de francs
impossible à financer dit elle son
déficit atteint déjà un milliard et demi
de francs
ce soir l'unedic a finalement trouvé 15
millions non dépensés l'an dernier qui
seront affectés à des aides d'urgence
de son côté le ministère de l'emploi a
débloqué 500 millions de francs pour
l'allocation de formation reclassement
simplement cette somme a déjà été
dépensée en 1997
autre revendication des chômeurs la
gratuité des transports
le ministre communiste jean claude
gayssot a fait un geste en accordant des
tarifs réduits
deux cent seize mille demandeurs
d'emplois en région parisienne quant à
l'extension du rmi aux moins de 25 ans
cette idée chère aux associations de
chômeurs est pour l'instant exclue par
les pouvoirs publics
nicole notât bonsoir alors vous avez
tenu cette réunion de l'unedic cet après
midi qui était prévu d'ailleurs et une
régulière mais évidemment on a beaucoup
parlé de ses problèmes de cette révolte
des chômeurs 15 millions est-ce que vous
pensez que ça va suffire à calmer cette
fronde qui s'étend dans toute la france
alors qu'on en est à des revendications
comme une prime de 3000 francs pour noël
ou encore une revalorisation des minima
sociaux et je voudrais d'abord dire que
je ne serai pas la responsabilité que je
suis à l'unedic au nom de la cfdt la
sienne et il n'aurait pas les
revendications qu'elle a depuis très
longtemps
la réduction de la durée du travail pour
l'emploi l'art de leur déploiement de la
réforme des charges sociales qui ne pèse
pas contre l'emploi de nouveaux emplois
à trouver de nouvelles richesses a créé
si son obsession n'était pas de trouver
une vraie réponse à la fois en terme
d'indemnisation parce que les gens qui
sont privés d'emploi ont besoin du
minimum vital pour vivre j'en parlerai
c'est le rôle de l'assurance chômage
mais où en même temps rien n'est mieux
que de retrouver un travail de retrouver
à l'emploi alors le temps de retrouver
ses emplois revenons à ce 15 millions
pour dérogation qui dépasse largement
oui parce que si vous voulez pour
replacer là je voyais les revendications
s'afficher sur votre écran il faut
replacer les responsabilités là où elles
sont le régime d'assurance chômage
il faut peut-être le dire parce qu'il ya
eu de la confusion dans qui fait quoi
qui est responsable de quoi travers ces
dernières semaines le régime d'assurance
chômage c'est un régime d'assurance
comme son nom l'indiqué qui reçoit des
cotisations des salariés et qui est fait
et d'épée les entreprises mais pour
apporter un revenu de remplacement quand
il nous arrive le coup dur du chômage
alors évidemment quand le chômage prend
aujourd'hui les proportions qui lui
prend le régime d'assurance chômage ne
peut plus lui tout seul suffire à
satisfaire ce besoin de minimum vital
dont
tout le monde aspire et qui est bien
légitime un assurance chômage
nous couvrons nous indemnisons un
million neuf cent mille personnes
vous voyez qu'il y en a encore beaucoup
à côté et c'est cela qui sont dans la
plus grande détresse parce que l
assurance chômage depuis un an
prenant conscience de ce problème
particulier pour ceux qui avaient les
plus basses allocations nous avons
revalorisé de 341 francs la location
hommes pour chaque personne
13 % d'augmentation en un an nous avons
fait une réforme des fonds sociaux pas
pour supprimer les fonds sociaux comme
cela a été dit mais pour qu'il soit
mieux adapté plus efficace plus
équitable plus transparent pour ceux qui
ne vous êtes contre l'idée au niveau de
chômage ou le sommes en france d'une
forme de jeudi entre guillemets de
salaire pour les chômeurs et voyez je
crois qu'il y ait un risque à ne pas
prendre il faut moi je crois à agir dans
trois directions
il ya la direction de l'indemnisation du
chômage pour ceux qui en parce qu'ils
ont cotisé parce qu'ils ont travaillé
l'assurance chômage doit les prendre en
compte que mieux possible c'est les
allocations on distribue 116 milliards
de francs d'allocations par an à
l'assurance chômage
il y à des cas de détresse ce sont ceux
qui sortent du filet de l'assurance
chômage
seulement cinq cent mille personnes en
assurant solidarité par l'état vous
voyez le décalage et puis d'autres qui
ne sont nulle part où dans le et rémy
dont il faut un filet de protection au
minimum pour ceux qui effectivement sont
dans le besoin il faut que chacun puisse
vivre se loger nourrir en attendant de
retrouver le pied à l'étrier
mais tout cela ça ne m'enlève pas le
sentiment de déclassement social
ça n'enlève pas le besoin de dignité de
reconnaissance sociale que les gens ont
besoin en s'insérant positivement la
société en barrant les ans les salariés
ne se dote façon l'un des classiques
définitivement qu'on a notre population
sous développée en france et elle est
durablement sous développés ceux qui
travaillent à côté auront la conscience
tranquille
peut-être feront t-il pendant quinze
jours semblant de pleurer parce que ces
pauvres gens
finira par penser que quand même on a un
peu pitié d'eux eh bien non il faut
apporter des réponses à ces gens là le
minimum qui leur permet de vivre des 100
vital hymne à la solidarité nationale
doit jouer pas seulement selon qu'un
réseau d'un homme non ça ne vous aide à
l'état ses dates autres institutions et
l'idée que l'unedic vient de conforter
qui a été décidé par l'état que des
préfets mobilise tous les fonds sociaux
vous savez il y en a regardé ça c'est
tous les fonds sociaux du département de
l'aisne dans des institutions
différentes vous voyez un peu le
parcours du combattant pour yervoy rise
bon ce qui veut dire qu'il faut
mobiliser tous les fonds qui lisant tous
les institutions foulée coordonnée
autour des préfets ce sera plus efficace
si je pense que de l'argent pour ceux
qui en ont plus besoin donc il faut
avancer dans ce sens là il les assedic
seront partis prenant rapidement des
questions plus politiques
on a entendu certains ministres comme
jean pierre chevènement qui comptait
beaucoup sur la réunion de munich pour
ans pour régler complètement le problème
aujourd'hui ils sont ils vont être déçus
aussi je crois non que jean pierre
chevènement est un homme avisé je pense
que c'était une manière peut-être de se
dire temps ci lui dit qu'ils pouvaient
faire un petit peu l'état en ferait
moins demain bon moi je vous savez je
n'ai pas le jeu ne fonctionne pas dans
cet esprit de ces la responsabilité bien
d'autres fois que tous les acteurs
aujourd'hui son remarque encore
concernés par les réformes a encore tout
cas c'est plus désobligeantes à votre
gars frédéric bobin ancien ministre
socialiste a dit que vous gériez
l'unedic comme une boutique hier c'est
l'expression qui a été employé c'est à
dire que s'il ya des fonds à partager
lorsqu'il ya un tir est à la fin de
l'année on se partageait en réduisant
les cotisations des salariés des
entreprises en ne pensant pas du tout
chômeur moi je pense que frédérique
bredin il sans doute mal informés d'une
part son propos n'est pas très agréable
je ne vais pas faire de commentaire
mais si elle veut signifier par là que
j'ai en tant que présidente et avec moi
beaucoup d'autres administrateurs de ce
régime
l'intention de jeux bien gérée ce régime
parce que c'est l'intérêt des demandeurs
d'emploi de pouvoir les indemniser parce
qu'un régime en déficit c'est un démon
un régime qui ne peut plus payer sa
failli nous arriver alors c'est vrai que
j'ai pas la conception de la gestion qui
l'a t a été celle du crédit lyonnais
pendant plusieurs années alors dernière
chose des chômeurs se rassemblent vous
avez des premières à dire qu'ils étaient
manipulés ce que vous le pensez toujours
par qui et contre qui si vous savez les
mots font toujours shop surtout quand on
les monte un peu en épingle en tout cas
tant que je serai dans cette fonction où
je n'y serai plus le jour je ne saurais
pas le plus le faire je n'accepterai
jamais ni de mentir ni ne pas dire la
réalité la vérité aux gens et quand j'ai
le sentiment qu'on emmène des gens dans
l'impasse ce qui m'a le plus on leur
fait croire mais tout simplement on leur
fait croire qu'il va être possible
d'avoir une prime ou que cette prime ils
font apporter des aides ponctuelles à
ceux qui en ont besoin
mais s'il faut l'argent nécessaire à
l'est cette prime
je préférais si quelqu'un était capable
de la débloquer qu'elles servent en
partie à l'augmentation des minima
sociaux parce qu'il faut y aller sur
l'augmentation des minima sociaux et ça
c'est l'état qui est responsable mais je
préfèrerais qu'on fasse plus de mesures
actives qu'on mette les gens à l'étrier
de l'emploi comme on l'a fait à l'unedic
plus de gens qui partent à 40 années de
cotisation parce qu'ils ont leurs
quarante années de retraite qui permet
d'embaucher des jeunes plus de gens qui
continuent qui reprennent un petit
travail qu'on indemnise en même temps
plus de 100 entreprises qui réduisent le
temps de travail parce que ça permet
d'embaucher des gens aient enfin ça leur
permet d'avoir un sentiment de dignité
de citoyenneté sociale et ont même temps
est revenu je remercie
l'actualité c'est encore retour sur une
affaire le 17 décembre dernier près de
dammarie-les-lys en seine-et-marne un
jeune homme était tué par une patrouille
de police alors que selon la version
officielle il cherchait pas foncé sur un
barrage passager qui se trouvait à ses
côtés gravement blessé vient de sortir
de l'hôpital ils témoignent et sa
version des faits n'a rien à voir avec
celle de la police y portent plainte
d'ailleurs pour tentative de meurtre
valérie fournis ou olivier caroff les
débats du tout
attention nous arriver jamel se remémore
ce soir lors il était sur cette route
la course poursuite avec les policiers
elle est entraîné la mort de son cousin
abdelkader 16 ans et le deuxième barrage
de la police ils le rencontrent à
chailly c'était pas un barrage si vous
voulez on été reçue le rouge la route à
droite
j'ai vu qu'un policer a
on vit en uniforme quoi ils étaient
braqués avec son pistolet son revolver
envers nos sessions de quoi elle nous
n'a pris cette direction tout droit par
direction direction fontainebleau voit
les policiers présents à ce carrefour
envoie alors un message radio à leurs
collègues de fontainebleau
attention ils ont essayé de nous [ __ ]
en l'air à chailly c'est le premier
point de divergence avec la police à
fontainebleau
la version des policiers qui les
attendaient à ce rond point n'est pas
non plus la même que celle de jamel
cette fois ils m'ont sorti de la voiture
qu'on commence à le brutaliser que j'ai
entendu un petit conte eu un petit coup
de l'impact soit pas un coup de feu mais
si vous voulez un bruit qui était déjà
la voiture était déjà on était sur la
rai madame emond sortie à l'arrêt de la
voiture
selon les policiers ce sont quatre coups
de feu qui ont été tirés mais en état de
légitime défense car la voiture
tentaient de forcer le barrage
enfin il était la tête sur le volant si
vous voulez des conditions il était
peut-être paix m après un petit short je
ne sais pas je peux quand vous dire mais
elle était pourtant potion les policiers
maintiennent que le conducteur était
déjà morts lorsqu'ils ont ouvert la
portière la police des polices enquête
elle attend maintenant les résultats de
l'expertisé balistique pour savoir dans
quelles conditions il a été tué après
les violences des dizaines de voitures
brûlées à strasbourg pendant les fêtes
de fin d'année des condamnation à de la
prison ferme pour les casseurs une table
ronde était organisée aujourd'hui à
strasbourg mettant en présence élus
magistrats policiers avantage christine
bost attiré curetage 85 carcasse de
voiture comme celle ci ont défiguré les
quartiers périphériques de strasbourg
depuis le 31 décembre
vestige d'une flambée de violences
exceptionnelle tellement exceptionnel
que certains s'interrogent sur leur
caractère spontané le c'est vrai que la
découverte
10 de danger
en quantité importante d'engins
incendiaires ou d'engins explosifs en
quantité importante
établi qu'il ya eu une organisation mais
l'organisation ça ne veut pas dire un
complot ou quoi que ce soit
l'organisation ça veut dire que
peut-être des bandes sont organisés pour
un certain moment
semer la perturbation des raisons que
j'ignore
edit ah oui c'est ça préméditation
habitations je pense que tout n'est pas
spontanée au ce sens que tout n'est pas
coup de folie ou de sang l'hypothèse de
dealers voulant détourner l'attention en
manipulant des jeunes ne convainc
personne dans les banlieues les dealers
dans un quartier ont tout intérêt qu
est-ce qu il ya une paix sociale parfois
c'est eux mêmes qu'ils organisent donc
l'idée de manipulation par les grands ne
semble pas tenir debout je dirais pour
même pas pour un sou j'ai envie de dire
et je m'excuse de l'expression je crois
pas que c'est quelque chose de
raisonnable
d'autres avancent des conflits entre
quartiers dont le règlement se ferait à
coup de voitures brûlées à chaque site
et son palmarès cette logique de
territoire prête à une espèce de
concurrencer un espèce de surenchère par
médias interposés à m'écouter le rapport
pervers entre les médias et les jeunes
il est incontestable elle est de la même
nature que des rapports à la police
c'est la jeunesse la police la
municipalité la justice bref les
institutions concernées ont affiché
aujourd'hui à l'occasion d'une table
ronde une volonté commune d'agir de
prévenir mais aussi de sanctionner le
ministère de l'éducation nationale se
lance dans une réforme de l'entrée en
sixième avec la volonté d'éviter l'échec
scolaire d'enfants qui quitte le
primaire sans savoir réellement lire et
écrire dans le domaine de la lutte
encore contre l'échec scolaire une
initiative à prendre en compte à reims
un professeur a décidé de récupérer au
niveau de la 3ème jusqu'à la terminale
tous les adolescents en situation
d'échec il veut les remettre dans le
circuit normal des études avec la
volonté de leur faire comprendre que
l'on peut apprendre avec plaisir en
quête de thibaut barbeyrac et jacques
gérard vous avez deux solutions pour soi
d'être des gens des individus en devenir
ou alors vous allez vous avez le choix
des individus déjà fini des élèves sages
et attentif
et pourtant dans leur passé l'école
buissonnière parfois la petite
délinquance ou la violence familiale à
l'arrivée pour tous
l'échec scolaire l'exclusion s'ils
reviennent à l'école c'est parce que
jean-luc mur ascione leur offre une
toute dernière chance il a été éducateur
en prison
aujourd'hui il fait le pari de les
réconcilier avec le savoir je crois que
le but est de déstresser un peu le
savoir et de de faire comprendre qu'on
peut apprendre avec plaisir que le
savoir c'est pas toujours liés à la mer
triture je crois que c'est une vieille
idée aussi et qu'il faut souffrir pour
pour apprendre non le savoir c'est un
plaisir
ils ont de 16 à 22 ans font 50 dans une
classe unique
certains préparent le bepc d'autres le
bac un mélange plutôt perturbant
pourtant en fin d'année il faudra
impérativement reprendre une scolarité
normale alors le travail se fait par
petits groupes avec le professeur un
professeur derrière lequel les élèves
trouvent enfin un adulte à l'ecoute si
l'enseignant cherche un petit peu à
savoir ce qui va ce qui ne va pas
chercher à partager quelque chose avec
l'élève avec chaque élève par cas
particulier je pense que l'élève se
sentir un peu mais il y aura demande
exclu retrouver la confiance dans
l'école mais aussi dans la vie ce soir
par exemple les élèves proposent à ce
restaurateur d'organiser dans son
établissement un débat sur la culture
corse un projet extrascolaires parmi
beaucoup d'autres
pour pouvoir passer à l'étape suivante
voler de leurs propres ailes
il ya un moment il suffit pas de dire il
faut aussi passer à l'acte
alors passer à l'acte c'est le risque
pour tomber dans l'échec est absolument
avoir le savoir nécessaire pour l'heure
d'une situation de collectivités est
vraiment à la hauteur ce qui fait
qu'après une dynamique se met en place
et un plat sur notre site et de courants
projet de jour en jour les élèves
reprennent goût aux études
jean dupuy raciale gagne son pari et
nous permet de partir de là deux on
présente la vie nous donne envie d'aller
plus loin je suis retrouvé le plus à
l'est sont en prison vers et depuis 13
ans qu'elle existe cette expérience est
une réussite pour huit élèves sur 10 des
élèves que le système avait jugé
irrécupérable la pollution en région
parisienne selon une étude menée entre
1991 et 1995
cette étude confirme les graves
conséquences de ce phénomène
atmosphérique sur la santé humaine la
pollution est génératrice de gêne
quotidienne du développement de l'asthme
ses enfants et même de décès josé blanc
la pierre pire moscovitch consultation
cet après midi à l'hôpital cochin
ici on soigne tout venant des maladies
respiratoires parmi les plus
préoccupantes l'asthme une maladie en
forte croissance d'après ce pneumologue
5 à 10 % des enfants sont asthmatiques
aujourd'hui les raisons sont multiples
on parle d'hérédité d'allergies mais
aujourd'hui un nouveau phénomène semble
prendre le dessus
la pollution de l'air les pics de
pollution sont un navigateur qui permet
éventuellement de tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé
mais la pollution au quotidien doit être
effectivement tout à fait étudier car je
vous rappelle que quand les gens fumer
pendant 2
nombreuses années ne savais pas que le
tabac était nocif un jour sur deux en
étaient vélo et jogging sont fortement
déconseillés ces jours là où pourtant la
pollution est qualifiée de moyenne
les hospitalisations pour asthme
augmente de 25%
les visites de sos médecins pour
problèmes respiratoires de 22%
aujourd'hui le simple fait de respirer
l'air des villes de plus en plus
médiocre est devenu dangereux pour la
santé
les effets sont une aggravation des
pathologies chez les personnes malades
ça peut être des gènes des symptômes et
rita pixellisation moment de santé et
c'est chez des personnes atteintes
gravement de pathologies ça peut aller
jusqu'à un jeu sur la passe hiver
autrement dit le droit de rouler les
jours de pics de pollution devrait être
annoncé la semaine prochaine un
pis-aller loin de pouvoir purifier l'air
que l'on respire chaque jour un début de
pénurie de vaccins tetra coq contre les
principales maladies infantiles
enregistrés dans certaines régions de
france les laboratoires mérieux qui
fabrique ces vaccins espère y remédier
très rapidement à l'origine de cette
pénurie des lots douteux qui ont dû être
retirés de la chaîne de production
benoît gadret et iris email baptiste est
l'un des rares enfants qui ces derniers
jours a pu être vaccinés avec le pentax
rock
le pentax aucune combinaison de cinq
vaccins différents qui protège le
nourrisson de la diphtérie du tétanos de
la polio de la coqueluche et d'une forme
de méningite
depuis le mois de septembre les
pharmaciens sont en rupture de ce vaccin
ce qui n'est pas sans poser de problème
ça direct ou les calendriers au niveau
des pédiatres et des médecins c'est à
dire que les rendez vous sont fixés
voire deux trois mois quatre mois al
avance puisque c'est des vaccinations
dans le temps et les médecins sont jette
décalé tous leurs rendez vous et nous on
leur promet des vaccins qu'on n'arrive
pas du tout à fournir sans aucune
explication
le pentax est produit par pasteur
mérieux qui disposent en france du
monopole ces derniers mois trois lot
défectueux portant à chaque fois sur
deux à trois cents mille unités ont été
identifiées des vaccins insuffisamment
actifs en particulier pour lutter contre
la coqueluche du coup pasteur mérieux a
dû interrompre ses livraisons production
biologique n'est jamais garanti à seront
à 100% c'est différent de la production
des médicaments inerte et il nous arrive
de temps en temps de rater un lot c'est
la première fois cependant que nous
avons plusieurs lots consécutifs qui
rate et qui nous met dans cette
difficulté d'approvisionnement
le pentax serait à nouveau disponible à
la fin du mois de mars
en attendant pasteur mérieux proposera
dès la semaine prochaine une solution
alternative avec trois vaccins
de l'avis de tous les spécialistes le
retard pris pour les rappels de
vaccination à sans conséquence fourni en
difficulté que depuis deux mois trois
mois donc on reprend là où on s'est
arrêté nous avons fait 2e et 3e
vaccination précisons enfin que les
rares lot de pâte à coke vendus en
pharmacie ces derniers mois ne présente
aucun risque
onze ans après la catastrophe nucléaire
de la centrale de tchernobyl bien la
centrale fait toujours peur son
directeur un ukrainien déclare que le
sarcophage de béton qui l'entourent
menace de s'effondrer
si des travaux de consolidation ne sont
pas engagées immédiatement les autorités
ukrainiennes voudrait que les fonds
promis par la communauté internationale
soit enfin débloqué patrice pollet
jean-marc sources 1986 une explosion
pour commencer dans l'atmosphère
l'équivalent radioactivité de vingt
bombes d'hiroshima
ensuite le sarcophage construit juste
après pour confiner les radioéléments
depuis sa mise en place ils résistent
plutôt mal aux affronts du temps vu de
l'intérieur des trous dans les parois et
surtout du béton fragilisé par la
radioactivité
aujourd'hui les responsables ukrainiens
affirment que le sarcophage est très
abîmée il menacerait de s'effondrer
le sarcophage c'est une structure
fragile
c'est une structure fragile qui a été
conçue construite dans l'urgence dans
une condition très difficile pour le
personnel et qui a maintenant 12 ans on
peut dire que cette structure ne
présente pas des garanties de stabilité
tel conte pour les avoir avec une
construction faite dans le calme et la
sérénité refaire tchernobyl un projet
gigantesque des travaux qui s'étaleront
sur 15 ans coût estimé à 900 millions de
dollars
pour le moment seuls 300 millions ont
été réunis par la communauté
internationale
mais malgré cela les ukrainiens ou
attaquer les travaux commencent pour que
l'on n'oublie définitivement la plus
grande catastrophe nucléaire civile en
algérie ce soir le gouvernement rejette
officiellement tout forme d' aide de
l'union européenne pour les populations
des régions touchées par les massacres
en algérie en algérie par dont justement
un nouveau carnage a eu lieu dans la
région de loire sonis dans l'ouest du
pays où des groupes armés auraient tué
70 personnes à paris à l'occasion de ses
voeux aux ambassadeurs en poste en
france le président de la république
jacques chirac s'est exprimé sur cette
violence au quotidien qui frappent
l'algérie
jacques chirac cette violence qui frappe
de manière barbare l'algérie et son
peuple et je tiens à exprimer devant
vous la profonde émotion de tous les
français devant ces massacres
d'innocents et dans cette épreuve
la france se sent solidaire de l'algérie
à laquelle elle souhaite apporter aide
et coopération à toulon le chef de
cabinet du maire front national monsieur
chevalier mise en examen pour avoir
couvert un employé municipal qui s'était
fait payer pour favoriser deux embauches
dans les services de la mairie s'était
contenté de faire rembourser la somme
perçue par cet employé indélicat
par ailleurs la justice de munich vient
d'ouvrir une enquête préliminaire contre
jean marie le pen qui récemment en
allemagne avait renouvelé son discours
sur les chambres à gaz détail de
l'histoire selon lui le parquet de
munich veut savoir exactement ce qui a
été dit par monsieur le pen
on savait possible de réaliser le
clonage d'animaux la fameuse brebis
dolly un chercheur américain a annoncé
aujourd'hui son intention de cloner
c'est-à-dire de reproduire à l'identique
des êtres humains pour le compte de
couples stériles
jean daniel flaysakier voici l'homme qui
veut oser riesch all sides n'est pas
médecin ni les physiciens et dans une
interview à la radio américaine
il annonce qu'il va clown et d être sur
mon grand projet c'est de créer une
clinique de l'infertilité dans la
banlieue de chicago
je vais créer une soixantaine d'emplois
et nous allons produire 500 clown
humains paru tout a commencé avec deux
nés à la fin 1996
dolly copie à l'identique de sa mère
conçue sans aucune fécondation le
premier clown et d'une cellule adulte
une cellule deux mamelles c'est cette
technique un peu améliorée que veut
utiliser sealed le principe on prend un
ovule dont on enlève le noyau qui
contient le matériel génétique
ce noyau est remplacé par celui de
cellules adultes prélevées sur le futur
père ou la future mère on réimplante et
si la grossesse se passe bien
naîtra un enfant qui ressemblera
physiquement trait pour trait qui aura
le même sexe que celui qui a donné la
cellule adulte les techniques restent
encore difficiles mais la science avance
preuve en est poli qu'il est ici à côté
de dolly ce mouton est né par une
technique de clonage qui s'est
extraordinairement améliorer le clonage
humain devient donc envisageable reste
la question morale on peut dire qu'il ya
un courant fort pour légitimer tonnage
humains aux états unis beaucoup plus
qu'en europe effectivement mais ses
traditionnels qu'il y ait une opposition
entre deux approches éthiques
on va dire plus lié au principe en
france et et en europe est plus liée
simplement à l'étude sans référence
avocat principe des conséquences aux
états unis donc on va bien voir
il est à craindre selon moi que la
puissance dominante gagne mais être à la
fois l'enfant est le jumeau de l'un de
ses parents sera sans doute très lourd à
assumer les psychanalystes ont de très
beaux jours devant eux
elle est une continue d'être la grande
aventure spatiale des américains de la
nasa qui viennent d'envoyer une sonde
qui tournera pendant un an et demi
autour de la lune pour réaliser une
carte complète de là
surface lunaire avec la grande question
toujours posée y at il oui ou non de
l'eau sur la lune normal bonnant jean
louis boulet depuis les premières
missions apollo dans les années 60
l'homme se pose toujours la même
question existe-t-il de l'eau caché
quelque part sur la lune
une dizaine de sondes automatiques ont
déjà été envoyés pour tenter de trouver
des indices
la dernière en date clémentine c'était
en 94
cette sonde franco américaine avait
permis de ramener des clichés sur l'un
d'entre eux un site qui intéresse les
scientifiques
il s'agit d'un cratère au fond du
gouffre à plus de 12 km de profondeur et
par moins de 130 degrés peut-être de
l'eau à l'état de glace c'est cette zone
que lui narre prospector devra et pied
en tournant autour de la lune à 100 km
d'altitude
après cinq jours de voyage la sonde aura
un an pour tenter de dénicher la glace
de la glace très précieuse pour les
futurs vols habités grâce à elle il
serait possible de fabriquer de
l'oxygène et de l'hydrogène on liquéfie
ces molécules on à de l'hydrogène
d'oxygène liquides qui sont des
carburants des moteurs de fusée longue à
ce moment là on peut utiliser des lunes
comme stations-services ont fait le
plein des réservoirs et on peut repartir
de la lune
l'invité beaucoup plus faible et
l'absence d'atmosphère fait que un
départ depuis la lune est beaucoup plus
facile sur le plan énergétique à départ
depuis la terre pour des missions très
lointaine de la glace sur la lune
l'hypothèse est loin cependant de faire
l'unanimité parmi la communauté
scientifique mais ma certitude pour
l'uranium et l'aluminium que la sonde
doit également recherché début 99
l'unarc prospector achèvera sa mission
en s'écrasant sur la lune à cet instant
l'astre aura peut être livré aux
terriens ses derniers secrets
sur terre johnny hallyday la star du
rock français qui reste indéboulonnable
et aujourd'hui en vacances quelque part
à l'étranger mais dans un entretien très
long entretien au journal le monde
celui que l'on appelait l'idole des
jeunes des années 60
ce livre comme il ne l'avait jamais fait
sur la drogue dont il dit avoir usé et
abusé
et puis le grand vide de sa vie
l'absence de famille laurent le job
vincent clerc
on la connaît la rock'n'roll attitude de
johnny hallyday le chanteur et sa propre
mythologie virilité puissance et gloire
il reste l'homme une face cachée qui
apparaît dans une interview accordée à
l'écrivain daniel rondeau pour le
journal le monde je suis un chanteur de
rock and roll et je ne changerai pas
c'est ma sincérité jusqu'à en crever
l'impression d'être un survivant ne me
quittent plus guère
il reste mitigé guerre et moi et moi je
suis comme ces grands malades qui ne se
battent plus que pour ne pas mourir
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas fait
différent tu ne fais pas de différence
entre entre sa vie et son métier de
chanteur s'énerve n'y a rien entre c'est
à dire quand d'ailleurs quand ils ne
quand il ne chante pas il vit une vie
presque au ralenti levier en mineur
la vie en mode mineur ou johnny hallyday
et ses démons intime
la faiblesse du tombeur de femmes en
quête de bonheur la fragilité du rockeur
en mal d'inspiration
avec souvent comme seul béquille la
droque la cocaïne
oui j'en ai pris longtemps on en demande
mon lit le matin maintenant c'est fini
j'en prends pour travailler pour
relancer la machine il n'ya pas à s'en
vanter
je n'en suis pas fier c'est ainsi c'est
tout jeune il avoue parce qu'il n'en a
rien à [ __ ]
parce que gianni pense que il n'a rien à
cacher et c'est très très bien l'autre
personnalités à l'avoir dit récemment
c'était françoise sagan en disant
effectivement je me drogue et ça ne
regarde que moi mais je ne conseille pas
aux autres de se droguer parce que
c'était effectivement dangereux
sa justification à lui johnny hallyday
la trouve dans le seul héritage laissé
par un père absent
une fêlure psychologique une peur
constante et obsessionnelle du vide fait
de la mort mourir dans l'action ne me
fait pas peur mais la certitude de
l'échéance inévitable et effrayante
attendre quelque chose qui va arriver
je crois que c'est le pire dans l'absolu
mon rêve c'est d'y passer violemment
sans m'en rendre compte comme piétine je
vois surpris non non parce que c'est au
salon wii l'année
c'est vrai qu'à une solitude qui est qui
est chez lui qui est constante depuis
j'aimais des années des années même même
cas je travaille avec lui
et toujours ce cette solitude qui est
vraiment propre à lui même
non non
non
oui
la confession de johnny hallyday restera
sûrement comme un exercice de franchise
inhabituelle dans le show business
français il en émane néanmoins un parfum
sulfureux qui tombe plutôt bien dans
quelques jours sort son nouvel album
puis et verglas sur le québec canada le
poids de l'eau gelée fait s'effondrer
des arbres et des lignes à haute tension
coince les ferrures des serrures des
voitures 750 mille foyers sont privés
d'électricité
la population est invitée à rester chez
elle pour ne pas risquer la chute ou les
accidents tomobile il ya tout de même eu
déjà quatre mois et puis chaque année en
suède aux limites du cercle arctique des
sculpteurs créer des oeuvres qui ne
virons qu'un temps jusqu'à la fonte des
glaces il s'agit là de la construction
d'un hôtel classique avec chambres
réception bar salon hôtel qui fermera au
printemps message emparés dans un
instant car les images ne sont pas là de
la glace au sable mais promis on en
reparlera au paris-dakar maintenant 7e
étape entre ce marin au maroc et zohra
temps mauritanie dans la catégorie moto
stéphane peterhansel qui remporte
l'étape et premier au classement général
dans la catégorie autos victoire du
japonais ozu cas au général jean-pierre
fontenay reste en tête viennent la fois
voilà paris dakar n'est pas là non plus
mais bien les deux qui va arriver
le paris dakar et l'asse s'était quelque
peu en sable dans la machine
yann lavoix l'étape la septième étape du
paris dakar et bien de l'agnu du paris
dakar nous repassons à la glace voilà
donc ce fameux hôtel construit dans le
cercle arctique par des sculpteurs
suédois pour l'instant il n'y a rien de
ce que je vous annonce ne se passe mais
ça ne devrait pas tarder alors c'est où
le cercle arctique
voilà l'inutilité de l'édifice ajoute à
saboter les murs les colonnes les
espaces de repos jusqu'au lustre tout
ici n'est que glace comme chaque hiver à
la lisière du cercle arctique des
milliers de touristes converge vers cet
hôtel car il s'agit là d'un hôtel dont
la direction vous garantit une
température comprise entre -3 et -8
degrés
ça me faisait un peu peur de dormir dans
cet hôtel je pensais mourir de froid
mais en fait c'est un endroit calme
reposant ça ressemble à une église mais
en plus jolie au printemps l'hôtel
fermera ses portes et fondera au soleil
l'an prochain sculpteur et architecte
suédois construirons une folie du même
genre pour que durent ces soirées
conviviales où l'on sirote sa vodka
pour moi ce sera sans glace merci bah là
on en vient maintenant paris-dakar 7e
étape donc entre le maroc et la
mauritanie
stéphane peterhansel remporte l'étape il
est premier au classement général
she knows who can japonais remporte
l'étape catégorie voiture et c'est
jean-pierre fontenay qui est le premier
essai yann lavoix qui commente
un soleil dans le désert cette figure
vous a été proposé par l'italien flavio
à graz il a accusé bonne réception grâce
au sol sableux nous de la mauritanie
gayon empruntera pour une année
tout le monde
après plus rien
les conditions sont donc idéales pour
stéphane peterhansel réputé le plus
rapide des motards il s'est imposé
aujourd'hui et a donc accentué son
avance au général
pourtant à vouloir aller trop vite
référence elle a failli tout gâcher la
deuxième partie de la spéciale j'ai
tellement consommer en fait que j'ai eu
très peur de ne pas pouvoir terminer
cette spéciale et donc les 150 derniers
kilomètres j'étais très peu au ralenti
mais sur un filet de gaz pour pour pas
un pur pas tomber en panne avant
l'arrivée vu du ciel rouler à 140
kilomètres heure sur cette piste ça n'a
rien d'effrayant
c'est incroyable ce que l'on peut se
faire de fausse idée non
jean-pierre fontenay premier aujourd'hui
à prouver que ce genre de piste convient
mieux aux autos elles peuvent à moindre
risque atteindre des moyennes élevées à
moins bien sûr que vous n'ayez un goût
prononcé pour le hors piste
voilà le rappel des principaux titres de
l'actualité de ce mercredi d'abord la
journée d'action nationale des chômeurs
réunion lui ai dit qu également qui est
va donner 15 millions de francs dette
d'urgence nicole notât notre invité
indique que l'unedic ne peut pas faire
plus qu'elle ne veut pas gérer l'unedic
comme le crédit lyonnais pollution sur
la région parisienne une enquête
officielle montre l'aggravation des
maladies et même des décès causés par ce
phénomène atmosphérique qui ne fait
qu'empirer dans un instant la météo
sophie davant 20h50 les t2 aura une
production française de marc rivière
demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra françois
bayrou président de force démocrate
président du groupe udf à l'assemblée
nationale
ici même demain soir vous retrouverez
benoît duquesne voilà je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée sur notre chaîne
bonsoir à bien